hey this is presh talwalkar
solve for the value of the following
expression
the first term is the square root of the
quantity
six plus two root three plus two root
two plus two root six
then subtract 1 divided by the square
root of the quantity 5 minus 2 root 6.
this is a no calculator question and
there are four answer choices
2
negative 1
root 3 plus root 2 and none of the above
i thank ahan for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
we will get started by analyzing the
terms under the square root
we have a root 3 a root 2 and a root 6
which is equal to root 3 times root 2.
so we'll just get started by calculating
the square of root 3 plus root 2.
expand this binomial
and then collect the three and the two
to get five
and this is equal to five plus two root
six
this is not the same as the four terms
under the square root but there are some
similarities
both of these expressions have two root
six
the expression we want to simplify has
six and that's one more than
five so we'll guess that we'll take the
square of one more
than root three plus root two
so let's square
one plus root three plus root two
we can solve this as a binomial where
one term is one and the other term is
root three plus root two
we'll expand the binomial
now we've already calculated the square
of root three plus root two
so we'll substitute
we can then simplify
and this is equal
to 6 plus 2 root 3 plus 2 root 2 plus 2
root 6 and that's exactly the expression
that we want to take the square root of
now just to simplify a little further
let's get rid of the parentheses right
here
if we take the square root of both sides
we get that 1 plus root 3 plus root 2 is
equal to the square root that we want to
simplify
so we'll substitute in
we've simplified part of the expression
now let's focus on the fraction
to simplify the fraction we'll multiply
the numerator and the denominator by the
conjugate which is the square root of
five plus two root six
notice that two root six
is less than five so both of these
square roots are positive terms
so we can multiply under the square
roots
this simplifies to be the square root of
5 plus 2 root 6
then the denominator becomes the square
root of the difference of squares we
have 5 squared minus the square of 2
root 6.
5 squared is equal to 25 and the square
of 2 root 6 is equal to 24.
25 minus 24 is equal to 1.
then the square root of 1 is equal to 1.
so this is all equal to the square root
of the quantity 5 plus 2 root 6.
but how can we further simplify this
well
we've already calculated that the square
of root 3 plus root 2 is equal to 5 plus
2 root 6.
so if we take the square root of both
sides we get the square root of the
quantity 5 plus 2 root 6 is equal to
root 3 plus root 2.
we can thus simplify this and substitute
in
so
this is equal to one plus root three
plus root two minus the quantity root
three plus root two
the root three plus root two will cancel
out and we are left with the answer of
one
this corresponds to d
none of the above
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
you